oops okay so I better better start start
this again
I had this sound off that's that's not
good
without the sound so on now whether this
sound no the sound is on okay so yeah I
was I was doing something something
terribly wrong
I had to sound switched off and then on
so it should should work fine now it's a
little bit weird because I definitely
remember to put it back on but then
someone switched it off again so there
were no um no well known players
blitzing at the moment so I'm going to
try a little bit of playing myself
it's normally working quite fine so
let's see okay I'm playing gone an
international master here from from
Russia and I have played him a number of
times I get the feeling I don't really
don't really know anything great yeah
like G for something crazy so I have to
do with with normal development I have
fun changed some some setup that now
enables me to be able to see the chat a
little bit better so I hope that I will
be able to to react a little bit more to
what you write it is sometimes difficult
to do all those things at once playing
yeah doing some hopefully meaningful
comments and and also answering
questions ok so let's see I'm going
Queen d2 year attacking age six that
looks kind of normal black is some
having some space disadvantage in the
center I have a nicely centralized
position but he is very solid it's not
so easy to get anything great going I
don't really see how to how to open up
the position
to my favor 95 is what I expect now so
that she puts some pressure on you for
no it's not okay yeah that's definitely
also move so what am I doing here maybe
I can prepare a forum like Bishop h2 and
f4
I'm not so much at home in those efore
type of positions all those chess books
in the background yes absolutely and
this and these that's not all of them I
am have I also have some non chess books
of course but this is my um this is my
study room where I have all the chess
stuff a4 it's just a little bit I mean
Bishop b5 was already interesting but I
wanted to stop this pawn first ask black
what he's going to do next
so is this an idea to get this F for
pushin is it possible to play 960 one
time yeah sure it is
it's sometimes not so easy to get an
opponent to be honest this is one of the
the pools on the ICC that is not so
that's not so full in in comparison okay
he has stopped he has definitely stopped
f4 man I mean not totally but but almost
okay I'm going to put a knight there and
force him to take basically and then f1
I hope that's a good idea
I'm not sure really but this f5 move can
be a liability or this f5 pawn this is
the the more correct way to to put it
yeah we to remember to play fast that's
true
I can take this Queen and now I don't
need to play fast I don't really know
what he thought about that this was nice
gifting gifting me a queen for the start
of this session this was good he
probably only thought and that I would
take with the bishop but I wanted to
keep my pawn so okay yeah let's go for
for a new game I will definitely try to
play a 960 game Layton I have got some I
get some comments about a recent video
that I uploaded I had the the privilege
to play a Nakamura last week and this
does not happen that often it is the
second game that I play against him on
my chest explained account on video and
so this means like you get him every
once every two thousand games and I
managed to win somehow even quickly
because he played a somewhat dubious
opening and yeah they were he had he
made some some of his remarks after the
game so it didn't really affect me I'm
used I'm used to getting getting some
some weird remarks sometimes how many
years have you been playing
about 25 years I started very late with
15 to start in a club that's really late
but it gives give some hope to people
who start late okay next game and Grand
Master varnish varnish who's who's the
sky Victor walk calmly akov okay
so he's doing some offbeat opening the
the center game I'm going to just
develop quickly him play with Ruby eight
this is in fact quite a dangerous line
for black it's not so easy to play
especially in blitz chess in a normal
time controls I would be a very
optimistic here but in in blitz it can
be very tricky so I have this this this
exchange is hanging all the time but if
he took it before I can recapture with
the night and have a really great
position so this wasn't wasn't really on
I'm a pawn up that's good news but what
am i doing next night age five to ask
him where the Queen goes maybe Bishop
age seven or some total maniac movies as
possible in the Queen s no good squares
this one aha so he just wants to
recapture with the pawned yes that's
interesting
yeah but not much else I mean I'm
basically glad to have the Queen strain
it but he definitely has some oh he took
with the night haha I was only expecting
and to take with the pawn to make my
night a totally offside piece but okay
let's see
did he win previous the previous game
that I played again Nakamura yes yeah he
won the first game and my total score I
mean I've only played him twice with
with the chest explained account but I'm
playing on the ICC since 1997 so it's
been a while and wow this guy is what
this is this guy doing to me here this
is a really cool tactic at the end he
will get this this back here right Wow
okay so 95 Bishop takes a 5 huh Wow
no but okay I can take f4 maybe this is
this is something I can take h7 first
Wow hmm I'm getting confused here yeah
I've played them with other I've played
with other accounts against my cam where
are tons of times and my score is is as
expected terrible
I have lost tons of games I think like
55 out of 50 or something should be the
score yeah I thought h6 maybe but can
still give the check this is a really
bad position that was a very nice shot
that you found there with Knight takes
d5 that's very nice
yeah he can still give this check on h7
I just hoped with h6 to confuse them a
little bit okay yeah let's see yeah if
you give me tips on the on the chat I
probably due to the lack I won't be able
to use them it's it's nice but it
doesn't help and it's it would be
against the rules of course so he took
on d5 and now
to take him takes on c6 this g6 so I'm
threatening g6 here now to trap the
bishop
maybe I'm managing to take on a5 and
take on f4 for for even a poor Napa it
would be awesome if I get this in my
outfit industry he just retreats okay so
I will take here and take here for for a
pawn up well this feels like a miracle
yeah he gets it back of course but but
still I was thinking that I'm here just
completely smoked me with this Knight
takes d5 but it it's not that terrible
it's just equal material no not going
down that easily it seems okay yeah it's
got active groups that much is clear huh
maybe I should have played this a bit
differently but it's not really
threatening that much I need to get some
stuff traded this g5 Roca Sam is an
annoying piece okay so I can't even go
Bishop b4 yeah maybe I should never go
ahead Bishop c4 I'm sorry this is a bad
idea I wonder is there some way forward
here something active I'm probably not
young like I'd like to I'd like to do
something active but it's really not
much going on him I'm a little bit down
on time maybe he wants to try I he seems
that he wants to try to win which might
might my g5 know I'm just better him
that's weird
i G force is weak now and I think I just
win the pawn it was a strange play not
at the better Bishop my bishop is
attacking c4 and G for both those moves
were hmm a little bit strange to be
friendly about it when does your book
will be published I'm finished writing
very very much and it will be probably
out in Jenin
in February or something because the
publisher is also he needs it needs to
do some things
why do you often get irritated by people
who play very fast yeah it what can I do
that doesn't it irritate you if your
opponent is playing very fast
it always imitates me okay I have them
the the rook behind the the passer so
according to those ancient rules
I should be golden and we need to open
up the the Queen side now I can also
play a 5 year for Zoop swung but taking
is probably better
yeah and now that's a Zeus money I
either get the Jeep on rolling or get to
the before so this is a lost endgame for
him yeah this was weird
February yeah probably this is this is
worldwide basically this release it will
be released in English from everyman
chest so it should be basically normal
global launch if you want yeah amazon
has info but it is wrong this is I don't
know where they get it from they they
even had had it as out of print at some
point quite quite weird do you think
you'll be over 16 2006 hundred or more
in a couple of years no no my my rating
stuck on 2404 for very long time and
only in the recent year managed to gain
a couple of points to get to do 2,450 so
I had a good good year but if I reach
2500 I would be ecstatic to be honest do
you do book signings no I'm not that
important I don't think this is going to
happen so what I probably will do is it
will be probably possible to get my book
signed here from from me okay I'm
playing g5 here in this game to to block
to block the the kingside play with
their form how many times have you tried
to become grandmaster here it's not so
easy to to do you know to be honest not
really I haven't really tried hard
because I'm I was only an amateur player
if you want when I was when I was still
working full time in my in my office job
and I left this job someone to go but
now I'm focusing on teaching
and not so much on my own game how many
times have you played against Caruana
and not that often he's not so regularly
on ICC but I think he's a very strong
blitz player and honor I mean at least
it fell to me because he plays very
young a very clean chess in his blitz
games it's a if you compare it to some
others very strong blitz players they
often have their the Blitz game yeah
they're the typical sort of somewhat
offbeat stuff and trying to complicate
things playing on time or whatever and
and Kiwanis just playing strong move
strong move strong move very tough I
think I want one game where some time
where you somewhat blunder the rook and
I lost everything else something like
that I got I got so many questions you
guys it's very nice but I have a hard
time to plant and do commentary okay um
I have to be cautious about this night
yeah the night coming to f5 and the
Queen coming to a7 now Bo both it's a
little bit a little bit annoying let's
cover this can you suggest a book for
intermediate players that's not so easy
what exactly is an intermediate player
so it said that's it's that's hard yeah
this is this definition I have to get
the Queen out of him
oh he's sacrificing the exchange that's
really good that's really a good move
Wow oh wow this this gets this gets
problematic because he will get a
fantastic night on f5 but okay my king
is is not lost yet around 1800 mm-hm
not so that's it's really not so easy on
that level of around 1800 I think what
what what many people do they they start
to focus on opening studies and while I
think opening studies normally get ya a
very bad press from from chess coaches I
don't think it's that terrible to do to
do some openings but some people are
totally overdoing it they only get book
after book after book on on some opening
that they they are interested in but
it's much more important to improve your
middle and endgame skills because this
is definitely at the spot where most
games are are still decided on the
amateur level you have very often it is
tactics and if it's not tactics then
it's some rather basic positional things
so it's um it's it's mostly about doing
the wrong things there was a mention of
user Puffs books yeah I like them very
much like them very much do you think
there's any cheating in blitz there is
cheating but I think much less than very
often is his thoughts I mean a very
often
here people okay they are cheating and
whatever and I don't think it's
happening that often to be honest I only
had a couple of instances where I think
the cheating was very obvious and it was
really really rare just a couple of
games basically okay I try to somehow
open this but we can be he can just go
g3 yeah this night is so annoying here
an f5 amazing
can I get my queen near his King somehow
he has all kinds of tricks
I think of Queen Bee aid b2 or something
like that objectively speaking I think
I'm okay here but it's a very very ugly
position to play against this strong
night okay no I should start with this
actually and then Queen b8 Queen B one
to really be be quick about it
Queen on h1 mate this is what I want to
do okay so I go here
Knight d5 check yeah I wonder if I can
play for a win here if I go here horses
insane they can take Queen takes and I
can check yeah I can I can try that it
is it is risky maybe I don't know if he
takes on g5 I have queen bee one oh this
is a good move
Oh queen g4 is made okay yeah this is
time two to one time to run to c6
have you tried to play the play Magnus
up I did I actually did and it is
interesting I am I made a video on that
but I lost it with some there was some
technical issue and somehow I lost this
video it was it was quite interesting i
am i managed to I did quite okay I think
I I think I beat 13 yield but just once
and he beat me quite a quite a lot so
where it's not so easy
this is computers is quite decent okay
I'm taking on edge for what our Kings is
six edge and have to run here right what
an ugly position I really hated yeah
with this those pesky nodes as it was
very nicely put by a strong player I'm
not sure which player what play of it
he said bishops are better but Knights
are more dangerous and this is
definitely true okay I won only 97 I
wanted to go Korea King b7 but he can
play Queen d5 shake so this means I'm
lost probably or maybe I can go here as
weird as a little
well I have two other most loose hmm am
I losing you as well it wouldn't
surprise me very much but maybe it's
just a draw know it yeah
maybe it's just a draw
Oh the decide didn't expect Queen e8 c6
Queenie and I can play I think still try
to win
mmm-hmm may I think he probably has some
drawers here I guess we see six this
would be some sort of draw like a
perpetual Queen f6 or something oh come
on you lose on time your buddy or not
what kind of thing is this oh you
forfeited on time I don't know what is
this really I mean I think I can do this
probably right intending this is
discovered checks and this this will be
a draw
oh no I can go away maybe I'm winning
hmm I don't know maybe I'm winning I
don't know okay let that start another
game
okay yeah this plane Magnus up it's
quite nice if you just want to kill time
it's it's nice and yeah well it's so
playing against the computer right it's
much more fun to to play against real
people like here on on the ICC so I'm
trying to get a new game due to the
second name are you polish no not really
um my my from a the name is of obviously
coming from my father's side and they
they're coming from from from an area
that at the time was was still German
before the Second World War and nowadays
those names are mostly considered a
Polish because now it's um it's it's
part of Poland but this is where the
name is coming from but I have no no
known relatives them it's oh go again
this guy had blundered his Queen earlier
so this time we get something else I
won't play you for so we get get a Kings
Indian actually okay
ah with Bishop g4 that's a rare line but
not a bad line yeah White has many
options I always like this one getting
this straight and so we get something
that is quite similar to my Roxy point
only with some some pieces traded I am
interesting if I go be three years 94
it's a funny little trick B 394 I am
then I don't really have a great place
for my Bishop I can go to g5 that's not
that bad okay maybe
it's not ideal though you don't really
want to go there but okay what is this
what oh wow what a nice idea
well I have never seen that motif Wow
who
I'm a little bit stunned here is there
any way to not lose a piece here
yeah bishop dat takes the fire and two
pieces are hanging Wow 95 I don't have
any anything here Wow 25 Queen edge Froy
threatening mate this is really the
problem Queen f6 amazing wow this is
great
that's three great I mean maybe it's
it's it's a well-known idea or something
but that's cool
yeah Queen B 70s 97 yeah this saves the
day I was at first thinking that I maybe
have some idea with that like winning a
couple of pawns but he he is definitely
totally okay him just the only thing
that I have have a slight hope if I get
this d6 pawn that maybe his offside
Queen provides me with some ideas okay
here is going rupee eight I guess 96 I
could probably like and check before and
he probably will he can just take it for
him
Knight takes g3 and I'm still lost but
Knight takes g3 at least he has to
sacrifice on g3 yeah yeah I just have
one pawn right
now I just have one pawn should take
before I wonder if I've ever seen that
tactic that really great I mean so let's
take stock one pawn I'm going to give up
this just this is just a waste of time
for a live stream dragging this on that
was great great stuff Bishop takes d4
Wow takes on e5 and I really I really
have no move here right I have I can
engine check this the only thing is that
I'm not seeing this bloody button that I
have to press for the engine but this is
very fun yeah taking on D form key one
key one from the US yeah that was really
great what he did there and still
shopped okay I'm going to play my my
ultra brutal Jami Samish variation
trying to play F 3 E 4 and made the guy
it happens surprisingly often
yeah we should be 392 castles before and
it's red key G 1 G 1 Wow I get questions
that are totally off topic right do I
like pizza yeah unfortunately I do but I
don't eat pizza at the moment I'm trying
to to to improve my health and lose some
weight so I'm not eating this kind of
stuff at the moment at least so he
allowed to play Bishop g5 that's nice
this pin is always a very annoying thing
for black so I'm going to castle there
was another question what limits do
you're playing poker and I don't play
poker anymore I was very interested in
in poker No Limit Hold'em
the standard game that everybody plays I
was very interested some years ago but I
quit at some point because my chest
suffered too much and I mean I was just
devoting more time to Poker than to
chess at this time and it got
frustrating that I I was really playing
bad shares and it frustrated me so I
stopped with the program and I couldn't
assembly can cannot do both I mean honor
on a decent level ok he went back to g7
here hmm how do I do that I want to play
H Froy I'm really getting the kingside
open interesting
it wasn't the bad beats that got to you
yeah I wasn't so great about about bad
beats this is probably very clear when
you watch my videos that I'm not so good
with them with taking those kind of
losses in poker that are totally luck
related but it was mostly because my
chest was too bad or was suffering too
much really if you I mean you have
probably some some more important things
to do but if you go to the feed website
and you look at look at my rating graph
you still see when I play poker it was a
big dip downwards so my c4 pawn is
hanging here and how do I do that now
yeah come on I put something here I need
to get something going here
trying to play em against this King with
age for Hudson Utley age for opening
opening things up maybe f4 f4 Bishop h4
you really have to be as brutal as
possible in this opening its the
queenside is just so weak any any normal
things don't do it have you played Jerry
on your channel that's very likely but
he is not revealing his account on ICC
I have never played Jerry from chess
network in a blitz game or something I
have challenged him a number of times
but he always declined I thought it
would be nice for the for the fans but
he he never wanted to play so what to do
what to do I need I need pieces near the
king so King age 1 and g3 is yeah it was
clear that he will snatch this but hmm
yeah maybe take it and we can go to e3
yeah that's not good I didn't really
think about that so much no that does
not look really good
poker chess any other games no not
really I mean there are of course other
interesting games I know that bridge is
supposed to be very interesting but I
never got got around to to look at it
McGavin of course as well but I always
felt that considering I mean I still
felt that I have some something to do in
chess and I can can i play for some
silly I need I need to do I need to play
for Trixie anyway and fortunately Queen
takes h6 is not threatened here King
takes Bishop h6 check he has got Queen
h5g for Queen h6 would be really cool to
get in but probably not working
yeah it's the kind of last last-ditch
attempt here to to do something but
Queen h6 sometimes you get the xin but
he's taking quite quite some time yeah
this is interesting he is threatening
Queen d1 here
I thought g5 maybe or something is this
something not really takes I mean that's
definitely this this whole thing is
definitely winning for black here
objectively but it's that something that
I can still try g4 I will take on d4 as
well
I really don't see a move I think I'm
just lost
yeah this didn't work out relief he
defended this well I cannot treat Queen
Sam if he takes Bishop d2 maybe but he
has rookie threa if he if he's really
finding nothing else he can play look
III know K I'm Queen e4 Knight still
lost
it really has a completely winning
position okay let's do this first but
this is not this so clear-cut h6 is
there's some threats maybe I should have
played g4 actually G form if I take on
age six years rupee one made wrong so he
I don't know what he's doing but it
looks like I'm making a some sort of
comeback him Bishop h6 I mean how is he
protecting that or rook h6 for that
matter then Queen h3 this is this is
this dangerous
Kingi I of the screen h5 king of for
Queen age 6 and T I'm getting to g6
which is quite tough for him g5 takes f6
and this is a big problem
maybe a Scott rook h4 hmm rook h4 maybe
but I can take a look at 780 coordinates
well no I can take now I can definitely
uh I have f7 know if I fell into this
trap
okay I can still fight
my pawns are strong yeah
this is okay well this is just a blitz
game ooh
okay this was very very lucky let's do
another one so many things to to reach
yeah but I think it's it's getting
better yeah I can see a little bit a
little bit more of the chat so who do
you think will win the next candidates
tournament hmm yeah I need to know who's
playing first hard to say
hard to say I think I mean there are
obvious candidates yeah when Caruana is
a very obvious candidate of course world
number two at the moment but there are
some players who I think can can do it
maybe it's just two weeks you know and I
I personally would like to see Chris
show it for some reason he's just yeah I
don't know I think he really has has the
stuff to to put up a great fight because
I think he's a player really he's
working hard on chess of course he's not
conveying this this this impression with
his with his kind of yeah this kind of
looks and so on but if he would really
get a world championship match I think
he would put a super super hard fight
but okay could can be anybody not
anybody but I mean it's it's not like
only one one person can win so we have a
we have a purse defense yeah and this is
an opening that I really don't know much
about but okay
it still looks fairly normal trying to
do something with with this okay it's
trading now maybe I can trade this like
we
six okay now this is this is okay yeah
the night trade should be okay but uh
yes if I saw it the moment saw it
precisely when I when I had played this
I'm not very well developed yeah and
there's pressure on c6 hmm they cannot
play c5 that's not good
okay I think I have to change it is six
I go eat six hoping that I will recover
this pawn which is maybe a faint hope
but maybe I will get it back I don't
know Knight b5 is the problem maybe at
least this is a problem Knights is seven
maybe I am manage night c4 and stuff but
okay he prevented that so he might play
c4 Knight c8 however and still he plays
your form I have to develop first
do you think that learning different
things like running playing football
singing or develop your positive can
improve your chest yeah I think so
definitely I actually think that that
when I played played lots of poker
it wasn't good for my chest in terms of
my results because I was simply not
devoting time to chess for study and and
sort of ya have this this chess mind in
a way but I think some some things that
that are typical of poker applicable to
chess some psychological things
especially like playing things that are
somewhat uncomfortable for your opponent
this this idea that I mean I always had
the idea should do that but it sort of
developed when I when I got this some
ideas about poker where you sometimes
have to play very aggressively just to
to sort of convey the sort of put fear
into your opponent and this is this is
in chess sometimes the case as well that
you should play more aggressively for
example to make him really am yeah if it
is uncomfortable for him okay so we get
some some tactics yeah that I to be
totally honest don't understand okay
he's going for the pawn ruler but I
don't really think this is enough I can
take a for him and now this is the
knight is hanging on beehive and I saw
her I don't really know I don't really
believe that maybe it is not like
totally lost for white but it it
certainly looks fishy okay I will I will
sacrifice
spec 456 I have a nice nah and run into
night it right
no no heavens no okay I run into 95 what
can you do okay so let's let's do
something with the apron just just start
with this
at least my king is relatively safe and
I know I'm blundering the a pawn
directly this this was stupid okay so
I'm really going downhill in this game
from from winning to better to to losing
yeah very nice so what to do now
better not blunder the knight yeah that
would definitely deuce so I'm trying to
set up some sort of fortress it really
should be a draw I believe of course he
can try for my for ages but it should be
a draw what I did is I put my my pawns
here on on light squares and the the
knight on g6 maybe I shouldn't have
played that hmm interesting
yeah I don't know maybe I shouldn't have
played that it wasn't necessary to give
him the the pesum not sure how bad it is
but it wasn't necessary at all -
probably still ok I would be really
surprised if this is a win somehow
if I play e5 some king somewhere King g5
it should be a draw still I can take
them not clear okay I can just stay
where I am what is the best most
practical piece of chess advice you've
ever heard
puh yeah that's difficult in in one in
one like in one one sentence or one
piece no I'm not married known that's it
this an easy question yeah the best
piece of advice Jam now I can I cannot
really tell I cannot really tell mmm
okay but how do I draw here I can still
try to stay but let me do something
maybe it's a it's totally wrong idea
King this is probably really the wrong
idea I know I shouldn't have done that
right hmm rook g1 now is good yeah this
probably as well habit maybe maybe I get
get to g5 nah okay maybe I'm not that in
that bad shape but I only have 20
seconds this is this is really a problem
and King to g5 this is going to be a
draw at least the position
hmm okay I'm getting ambitious here
before f4 and stuff I mean why why does
it's over for wide in terms of winning
and that much is clear I won't get f3 in
here as this says this had some Suk's 1
characteristics
now I'm not losing this anymore maybe on
time but but not the position it just
totally screwed this up right now I'm
winning with this check I thought I'm
winning but maybe I'm not I cannot go I
can't I have to prepare f2
hmm
yeah yeah I'm losing one time because I
wanted to win and it's probably not
possible but okay do we have a job apart
from chess no not anymore I'm doing just
professionally now I mean not playing at
teaching how come you haven't played
Kings gambit in ages that's true that's
true yeah I have played a little bit
less funny form in my blitz games
recently played more d4 Knight a3 and so
on favorite game of the world
championship match
I think probably game game two I guess I
liked how cars and slowly build up this
pressure from this nothing opening with
Luke a3 and so on
when is your next life tournament not
sure I have plans for next year
obviously play to play the Reykjavik
open
how good do you have to be in chess in
order to make a living off just
tournament money top 30 maybe top 20 I
mean though those guys can can do a
decent living simply because they okay
now I get an interesting game yeah well
I will do this this this brutal attack
eeeh and hope it did works this is one
of my most frequent opponent Yong Tae
Yong
kallu de Moura de Moura great name
Italian international master and he has
an excellent score against me really
good player let's see I want to of
castlelong and then try to to meet him
try to meet the opponent is always good
at least the try is good so how am i
doing that so castle that's right I
decide this Knight is always hanging are
you still searching for chess pupils
yeah I do
it's um I still take students takes only
three let's see yeah that's a request I
should do a bullet session on a sec I
can I can do that yeah I'm my bullet is
certainly very rusty but because I
simply don't play but it's I'm not so
terrible in this time control
surprisingly so I'm going look this is
this move was surprising to me that he
allowed me to build up more pressure on
G form okay rook h3 may be coming not
sure if it is that great
and I should do one thing my nightie on
c8 yeah this is really a lousy piece I
on c6 is really lousy F to get this into
the game
if you have any inquiries about them
about my my teaching activities or
others you can write to me on youtube
you can you can write a mail to me or
you can message me on ICC this is the
the best way to do it and now g4 is
really really a problem how is he
protecting that I don't see how what do
you think about kills on William she
most alleged spaceship adoption story
that's a cool question I think it's
great actually that people are that
crazy sometimes they shouldn't run
international chess Federation's maybe
other than that I think it's brilliant
okay so can I take this or not probably
not right
there's something I can do Knight f3
look at five um I can still take it
where from Germany are you actually I'm
from from the Rhine world area deuce
book if you're in Germany you probably
know the city is not so well known
outside Germany f6 it's a industrial
area in the west of Germany
so look h3 that's really nice am I'm
just a pawn up here and and it's not
really a parent what he has for it
um this g4 may be possible here's
something I really want to get this
night into the game it's not doing
anything and it would be surprising if I
can win without it okay so he's
attacking f6 hmm okay I can tick III
though no I cannot wow this is a nice
Anderson ation I cannot take that mm-hmm
do I cover it yeah this all passive huh
a little bit passive
I don't see a good move him if you
played against Gianluca camera or semen
artist Stein I have played against ACTA
Stein I'm always skewing this name oh
yeah I've played him I think two or
three times and I have a good score I
think I had to be perfectly honest thing
he's not so great in blitz he's really a
strong strong player but it's not such a
brilliant blitz player I think I can go
here actually threatening checkmate
look edge one made it's quite dangerous
can I get a winning against the sky I
really have a terrible score against
them so I can take here yeah I can and
we'll take there's still rookie one made
in the mix so what am i doing now can
still take f6 right I want I really want
this night into the game can I do this
somehow Knight a5 or something to take
on on b3 yeah maybe I don't really see
something great that you can do and take
f6 of course but if I take here I'm
threatening 92 which is really serious
what is this a queen g8 Queen b3 yeah
that's a dirty trick that's a really
dirty trick okay I'm going to go to
approach with my Queen Queen f3 coming
if I would have taken yet Queen g8 yeah
funny
someone is writing I do not do pay
policy another way to support the
YouTube channel
oh yeah tell your friends tell your
friends so this is perfectly ok ok I
still cannot go here I think so I'm
going to return this wasn't very
successful maybe I could have taken d3
but ok I'm threatening that and he's
down on time so I'm still pretty much
relaxed iam hmm I don't want to trade
Queens but well it does win right
it does win with 97 ok come on let's do
that I just win this I just win no in
the pawn here I can actually even take
care father for this weird weird thing
this is Fox check here an idea form for
a winning Luke end game and he's got 10
seconds which is really helpful okay I
will pick up the whole Queen side okay I
wanted to make the move and he had lost
some time and I'm going to try one
little thing here I'm going to try this
960 game that people requested maybe I
get this in there's a question you only
need to need a rating of 2500 and norms
yeah it's read grandmaster norms and
yeah you have beaten GMS on youtube
before yeah this is blitz chess this is
this is a different thing in blitz chess
actually think that I'm not far away
from Grand Master strength but in in
over the board tournament chance getting
a grandmaster norm it's not easy at all
at least for me I always when I'm gonna
playing those tournaments I calculate
what I need to do in the in the last
rounds and it feels like yeah very tough
okay I'm trying for 960 game I have
requested it and I know we're already a
little bit over time but I want to do it
as bonus if possible
what's the strongest rating you've ever
beaten in tournament chess
I won a one in game against Grand Master
Mike Agora which once his peak rating
was 2700 something but at the time he
was rated 2600 ah I get a 960 game so we
get a bonus here against Ray Ray from
Antarctica so 960 let's let's somehow
try to understand what's going on here
there is nothing hanging yet this is the
first thing to check is there something
hanging does he attack something okay I
go I went with b6 trying to get this
Bishop out maybe I can go c5 yeah maybe
c5 so Bishop c7 will become an option
okay so we will be symmetrical okay
this is something something like the
exchange Slav of the of this 960
position I guess we play three one time
control that's really a different
different thing so hmm Knight only three
and maybe I should control some of the
center with my pawns it's probably a
good idea and h4 interesting
okay see and maybe he wants to play pawn
all the way to age six sir this this as
possible but I have Bishop f6 as well
which is not that bad probably just
trying to trade off this bishop and if
he takes my G file opens up yeah now my
G file opens up this Lucas is on an open
file that's okay and I don't mind the
double pawn that much they the double
points provide some nice control of the
center what I'm worried about at least a
little bit is it's my night on f8 which
cannot go to g6 but okay I went f5 to
get this in to play the Queen into play
okay is playing Bishop f4 but I don't
really fear the capture him
so maybe h6 Knight age 795 uninteresting
the Queen is activated I can go to e5
this is an idea this is an active post
for the Queen and the Queen is hanging
so he cannot just take on c6 yeah this
is now I think nice for me yeah I have a
good central control a good Bishop on
ahead this looks this looks quite quite
nice and f4 is an important move I'm
getting at the c4 pawn yeah I'd like to
play 960 it's really interesting but
it's very difficult to get a position
especially stronger or position there
are simply very few players who want to
play it and this means if you if I try
to do a recording for that I tried on
ICC and on other servers and other
servers is even worse of course they
have less players but it was very
difficult to get them to get any
opponent takes a very long time I wanted
to prevent Knight g4 but maybe night too
III now is an option okay can go if five
though yeah this will definitely be them
the last the last game I stumbled into
into this pin here wow this is really
bad I have to play d5 now he can take
now and take only five and I have the
worst ever pawn structure oh my god yeah
I'm lost yeah I'm lost here if he takes
c4 it takes you five I'm just lost who
hmm I wonder what he's doing here you
can really just take c4 and take e5 and
I'm totally toast Wow I mean my pawn
structure is a complete wreck
and c4 is dropping yes oh my god okay
wow I really stumbled into this what is
this I'm six five I'm one pawn down and
I have a terrible destruction great
maybe maybe I can can somehow provoke
him into do something stupid
taking on before for example have such a
sorcerer move but it's not happening
he's playing this alright
okay I still early only has four seconds
and he's really slow in a shallow often
Medrano I think I offer him a draw here
now I declined I mean of course this
position is much better for him but he I
think he will lose on time yes yeah he
lost some time I offered him a draw it
he didn't accept it I'm just lost here
of course some corn down and there's no
compensation yeah d5 g5 was I mean I was
I needed to play the move ultimately but
that's not not really
Wow that was not really good okay we are
almost 12 minutes above above the the
schedule I hope you enjoyed this I think
we did a little bit more of answering
question you had a so shiny yeah I don't
polish it but it's okay yeah I learned
English in school
but I try to I try to improve it with
them with watching lots of English TV
series and things like that okay I hope
you enjoyed it I'll be back next week
next next Monday the same time I will
also announce it on the channel again
but it should be a regular feature we
only went to I think it was last
Wednesday when the World Championship
match was sort of in the way okay I'm
going to say bye for now I'm back next
week I hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching